es Luffy más fuerte que kaido después de
más de un año de puñetazos sin parar
caído finalmente ha sido Derrotado lo
que creó un gran debate sobre si Luffy
Realmente está al nivel del yonko Es
verdad que el girl resultó ser
inmensamente poderoso y Luffy terminó
ganando la eterna batalla contra kaido
pero hay que tener en cuenta que
mientras Luffy fue noqueado tres veces y
tuvo tiempo para recuperarse kaido
estaba repartiéndole madrazos a todo el
mundo peleó contra los Samurai consoro
kit yamato y el mismo Luffy todo esto
mientras el cabrón sostenía en el aire
la resistencia y poder de kaido son tan
absurdas que El infeliz aún después de
pelear contra medio One Piece logró
igualar el giffire de Luffy está claro
que Luffy se ha vuelto muy poderoso pero
aún le falta tiempo para llegar al nivel
de kaido Pues si la pelea hubiera sido
un uno contra uno solamente que ha ido
contra Luffy kaidol hubiera roto su
elástica madre